soft robots might be the next big thing
but right now they're very delicate any
small rips or punctures could render
these devices unusable to combat this
researchers have built soft robots with
the material that with the little heat
it can reassemble itself after some
types of damage the robots get this
healing factor from their construction
they are made entirely of a synthetic
material called an elastomer short for
elastic polymer when heated the
molecular bonds to keep the elastomer
together loosen and begin to reform back
to their original cube-like shape a
little over an hour after being damaged
the material was almost completely
healed and 24 hours that for cooling the
only evidence with the small star in
testing this material was adapted to a
robotic hand a gripping claw and an
artificial muscle each one represents a
standard use for soft robot and each one
was successfully able to heal when
heated the robots could withstand cuts
and stabs and achieves nearly full
performance once healed even after to
healing cycles the robots could still
perform well the researchers saved these
self-healing elastomers could make soft
robots more commonplace now that their
weakness for pointy objects has been
eliminated
[Music]